as right here we are making video still
talking movies because never
underestimate the power of the human
spirit it's not even one of the worst
lines of the movie one of the more
memorable not one of the worst anyhow
the time has come
[Music]
Mortal Kombat annihilation
Mortal Kombat annihilation the sequel to
the first Mortal Kombat movie
annihilation came out in November 1997
if I'm remembering correctly he was
around winter 97 my brother and I
watched it got back my dad was like was
better than the first one we're both
like and my brother goes not exactly
we've been bagging on it ever since it's
taken me this long to review this movie
I know like quite a few people are
learning you should totally talk about
this movie and I think the main hang-up
is I'd have to watch it again it's just
really it's hard for me to get through
it's just painful for me to watch and
there's a lot to talk about about what's
wrong with this movie so the world were
at this movie supplying such a vast
array of multiple choice options to
choose from we're gonna select a few
things anyway and talk about those funny
enough the movie does something it
probably shouldn't have done it does the
recap which a recap is usually it's
generally very appreciated however if
you're watching Mortal Kombat
annihilation you've probably seen the
first one who's gonna jump on
annihilation be like oh screw the first
one you got to watch the second one
that's where you start so I don't think
it's necessary but also rule of contrast
is really working against this movie you
see footage from the first Mortal Kombat
movie the the much more competently made
Mortal Kombat movie so when you go from
footage from the first Mortal Kombat
movie and then OH to annihilation you
immediately see the difference in
quality and then from there there's just
immediately you're like is who made this
everything from the terrible CGI the bad
green screen King the backgrounds
literally clipping through characters
shoulders and objects you see the
[ __ ] seam in the cgi sky we'll get
back to the CGI a little later because
there is a lot to talk about when it
comes to CGI
yeah my favorite part in the intro is
the fact that you can hear Shao Kahn
laughing his way through the dialogue
you will never rule this world as long
as the portal remains open your world
becomes my world tell me he's not trying
his best to hold back that laugh funny
no this movie gets a lot of [ __ ] for the
fact that Johnny Cage died in the intro
[ __ ] me I'm still talking about the
intro but I mean he dies in the intro
it's totally different actually you
don't have linden ashby as Johnny Cage
which I actually understood when I first
saw it because the story at the time was
Johnny Cage died between Mortal Kombat 2
& 3 when Outworld did its siege on earth
before Mortal Kombat 3 started Johnny
that's when he died but now he's looking
at it you're like now you can you could
have fleshed that out and had him die
better at least he has you know aligned
weird I even started about this movie
look what's the worst you know like
where do we even pick we picked the porn
quality acting too bad you die it's
movies porn acting without any of the
fun that comes between the acting
imports like I said of [ __ ] you have
fights we picked the ps1 CGI the subpar
cosplay costumes the looking past any of
that like if you if you can just look
past it the biggest tragedy in this
movie for me it's just the lack of
character and lore Mortal Kombat was the
spearhead of lore among fighting games
it was next level sorcerers and another
realm Elder Gods changed how I viewed
fighting games and this movie just
doesn't really incorporate any of it or
it's in here but it's in here in the
capacity that someone just never played
Mortal Kombat and thought they could
just make [ __ ] up I don't know I don't
know why you have to make things up you
have enough lore to pick from yes I'll
find it all but what we really want is a
dragon tattoo that comes to life upon
the defeats and death of somebody and
flies away and disappears also that
dragon tattoo is an heirloom of Raiden
and Shao Kahn because they're brothers I
guess also that Dragon Tattoo is a fast
pass in between realms because Mortal
Kombat just isn't crazy enough without
that made-up [ __ ] how do you make this
stuff up like that's the kind of stuff
people come up with and I'm like why was
that necessary in this movie it's like
they were like I don't know let's just
try to make Mortal Kombat lore worse
than it has to be
I'm not saying more
combat lawyers bad I think it's cool
it's just someone wanted to make it
worse you can tell that they've never
played a mortal combat game and don't
know the Mortal Kombat characters by the
descriptor they gives striker two of our
best warriors have already been taken
cabal and striker one of Earth realms
greatest warriors sorry
no Koran and Mortal Kombat annihilation
does come from a time when I feel like
the concept of video game movies as seen
in annihilation and Super Mario Brothers
and even Street Fighter was like alright
we'll write a movie and then just throw
video game characters in it you don't
have to know about the characters of the
Lord will just have the characters in
this movie that could have been just any
other movie but even by that standard
annihilation it's just the worst of it
and the lack of understanding of
character and lore is seen by characters
who don't have relationships who should
have a relationship of some sort the
story of smoke and sub-zero is that
smoke was sub-zero's friend and then he
was assimilated and he became a cyborg
against his will sub-zero wants to get
him out of that that's a really
compelling thing it's so cool I thought
it was a cool story in three then when I
was watching the movie sub-zero just
freezes it was like our eyes frozen
alright now kick him so we can blow up
you have [ __ ] that guy oh that's when
I was like they've never played the game
yeah spinning fast travel hamster balls
in the center of the earth that didn't
tip me off but the lack of sub-zero
smoke lure that was it and that lack of
relationship was even seen by the
matchups like the matchups don't really
make sense Melina and Sonya fight in the
mud with the lamest fatality ever okay I
guess that's that stiff competition for
the lamest fatality ever at least but
Melina fighting Sonya why isn't Melina
fighting katana I imagine that would be
the face Iraq's going after Sonya and
Jack's what okay why though this movie
has no link way at all it's a shout cons
is a big baddie there are no other
factions there's so many factions in
mortal combat this really has this movie
s2 it's someone to make a fight happen
for the [ __ ] of it Jax we're gonna roll
with it and that's all the explanation
we're gonna get that's really what this
movie feels like it feels like all the
matchups and all the deaths it was
because you have your canonical fights
right you have characters that fight
each other in Mortal Kombat because it
makes sense and you have the non-canon
fights which are essentially when two
players get together and they just pick
a character and they fight but quarters
in the machine and they fight in the
arcade
but those aren't the canonical fights
though it's just called people fighting
in arcades but those that's what these
fights are somehow someone's like okay
well we're gonna make those the fights
in the second movie but at least you
have Sonia and Jack spelling around
together they're not pals like that was
one of the big disappointments like
Sonia and Jax are supposed to be close
they're partners it's supposed to be
really tight but the whole time Jax is
like can you please explain what's going
on she's like no she never explains it
to him she just looks annoyed and she's
like look okay no one told me why Johnny
had to die
we need to stop the merger I'm not gonna
explain more than that and he just gets
irritated the whole time and then you
get it well you would get annoyed if you
ever thought the movie was making any
sense but you're not even invested
enough to get it no but it does hit
you're like weren't you explaining the
situation is Jax where you're keeping
them in the dark it's really stupid you
know another thing that cracks me up
other than Shao Kahn I'm just starting
to hold back his laugh the riding stunt
double I mean that's not James remar is
that Ray part I looked into it that he
looks like Ray Park and I know Ray Park
is a stuntman in this movie but he's not
credited for Raiden last I checked but
that totally looks like right part and
after Raiden / Raiden stunt double is
clearly fighting reptiles here's the end
of it all right we got Sindel I guess
that happened so other than the porn
acting the costumes and the script tell
me did you make them beg for their lives
before you destroyed them what on your
poker face debut like ah of course I
made the beg for their lives obviously
because this guy's gonna what [ __ ]
kill me with a hammer if I didn't
there's a dumbest boss every just keeps
killing people kills rain for the [ __ ]
of it kills Jade for the [ __ ] of it
because you know Mortal Kombat death is
what it's known for the editing makes
this movie completely incomprehensible
it's like characters go from one place
to the other and then they're there and
now they're there fast traveling
everywhere maybe they're all using the
hamster ball
speaking of editing let's check out that
Shiva fight
all right well that's it she was gone
now but at least we have Anna maladies I
[Music]
mean when I saw Anna maladies in the
movie I was like oh so there's animality
Anna maladies aren't that fun extra
thing this is a this is a thing in lore
now this is canon this is happening in
the movie no babe a ladies which Shao
Kahn has an animality what was he
hanging out with night wolf finished
spare time learning the power of
animality and the CGI bad is just a word
so is dog [ __ ] spoiler alert but that
animality fight is just next-level
Lou Kings dragon doesn't even look like
Liu Kang's dragon Liu Kang's dragon you
know whether it be his dragon fatality
is animality it has that mortal combat
dragon look to it it consistently looks
generally the same this looks like a
five-year-old drew a dragon and they
were like oh just my kid drew this and
I'm gonna translate that to the movie I
just gotta think at a point when you're
a filmmaker you got to make that colic
okay we can't make the CGI look good so
let's just not have that thing there
were no animality in this movie what
would have been like there's no [ __ ]
animality is what now the movie sucks
but now really the thing that people
remember about your movie is the bad CGI
in the animality fight whatever that is
but at least it very quickly and
abruptly ends after that in the end this
woulda can say about Mortal Kombat
annihilation like Mortal Kombat 1 was a
genuine attempt at bringing Mortal
Kombat to the big screen it had the
Mortal Kombat Lord generally speaking me
the sub-zero scorpion thing that kind of
just breezed right over but I always
kind of understood that because it's
that is thick enough to have its own
movie the characters felt like the
characters carry Hiroyuki Tagawa is
Shang soon forever he's even Shang Tsung
and MK 11 the game it's amazing gone is
any of that villainous charisma and
annihilation where will combat won the
movie was a genuine attempt to bring the
characters and the lore to the big
screen and you have fights in there
because it's a Mortal Kombat movie and
you kind of have to Mortal Kombat
annihilation was just a series of fights
that were just lined up to make a movie
and they were like we'll just [ __ ] out a
plot to put in between the fights to
paste it all together and it makes you
feel like there's no real story and
annihilation I mean there's the general
store
outworlds invading but there's no real
cohesive fleshed out story carrying you
from the beginning to the end for
justifying any of the fight it's just a
series of fights that happen it's a
movie that under the right circumstances
if you have a friend with you
you can try to watch it and just you
talk [ __ ] to the entire thing no one
watches Mortal Kombat annihilation and
pure silence like alright we got this
now it's a [ __ ] talk fest the more
people the better of the video game
adaptations out there Mortal Kombat
annihilation holds its place among the
worst and I got to say Mortal Kombat
annihilation is [ __ ] ecology are my
thoughts of Mortal Kombat annihilation
maybe I won't ever watch the movie again
though I'm sure some friends and I'll
pop it in at some point
have you seen it what did you think
about it is it a movie that's so bad
it's actually fun for you or is it just
bad whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]